je suis pas remis
ar c'est parce qu'il y a 10 ans et 2
mois j'ai dû me poser une question
une question
envie de vous poser aujourd'hui dans
votre mail
ou plus exactement au coeur de votre
activité quotidienne
souhaitez-vous faire partie du problème
ou contribuer aux solutions
le 15 septembre 2008
je travaillais pour la banque lehman
brothers parce qu'elle a fait faillite
et déclencha une énième crise de la
bourse crise politique sociale et
économique
j'étais dans la salle de marché
à londres une des plus grandes salles de
marché en europe à cette faillite ont
été associés les dérives de la finance
une finance qui socialiser les pertes et
privatiser les gars une fille lansky
privilégier la croissance et une
économie de la mondialisation une
finance qui privilégié le profit sans se
soucier des conséquences sociales et
environnementales
la question la plus importante c'est de
se dire aujourd'hui
est ce que ça a changé la financent
normalement devrait servir
l'investissement et l'investissement
préparer l'avenir c'est le cas quand une
entreprise investit dans des personnes
investi dans du matériel et dans des
technologies
c'est le cas quand le gouvernement
investit dans des infrastructures ou
dans l'éducation
alors pourquoi cette finance et à
l'investissement lié à la finance est
toujours lié cette image de profits et
de spéculations je suis parmi vous ce
soir c'est parce que j'ai réussi à
quitter mes écrans pour me tourner vers
le vivant avant la crise financière de
2008 il ya eu une crise en 2007 une
crise agricole où tous les produits de
base et les céréales notamment ont vu
leurs prix très fortement augmenté et
provoqué les émeutes de la faim des
investisseurs des financiers venez voir
mon équipe pour structurer la chatte
terre agricole des terres en afrique et
des terres en amérique du sud
produire massivement en nos cultures une
nourriture qui devait satisfaire
l'augmentation de la population qu'on
prévoit bientôt à 9 milliards
selon moi ce n'était pas une solution
quand je recherche des solutions ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir des solutions
à long terme
comment on peut mettre en place une
solution qui va rassembler de plus en
plus de personnes pour accoucher d'un
nouveau système là en 2007 à solution
qu'on proposait c'était du quantitatif à
court terme
privilégier ce type de production c'est
appauvrir les sols détruire la
biodiversité produire une nourriture à
bas coût qui est beau mais sur la
planète mauvaise pour les personnes et
destructrice des communautés agricoles
alors j'ai réfléchi et j'ai considéré
que en fait pour pouvoir se positionner
sur une solution du système alimentaire
il fallait passer par trois autres axes
que sont la qualité la logistique et
l'éducation
investir sur ces trois axes de
développement demandent justement des
investisseurs qui ont une vision à long
terme pas uniquement la maximisation
financière mais qui savent se
positionner pour une valeur globale pour
une solution dans son ensemble la
qualité parce que remettent les éléments
nutritionnels en trombe dont nous avons
besoin dans notre nourriture sans
additifs chimiques qui nous rendent
malades
c'est la base la logistique puisque en
amont et en aval sur la chaîne
alimentaire plus de 30 % de la
nourriture est gâchée l'éducation pour
arrêter de croire que nous pouvons avoir
tout tout de suite de n'importe où la
nutrition d'ailleurs nous apprend que en
été nous avons besoin d'une nourriture
qui nous hydrate en hiver une nourriture
qui nous apporte de l'énergie donc
consommer des tomates en hiver et
physiologiquement ridicule et
économiquement une catastrophe
ce qu'il faut savoir également depuis
2008 sait que peu de choses ont changé
en finance mais beaucoup de personnes
ont changé leurs priorités
la finance s'est à peu près les marchés
financiers deux cent mille milliards
sur ces 200 mille milliards 80 mille
milliards sont gérés par les grandes
compagnies d'assurance et les banques
les gestionnaires d'actifs 80 mille
milliards c'est également l'équivalent
du pib du pib mondial
c'est à dire ce que tous les pays
produisent comme richesse durant une
année
lorsqu'on regarde justement un autre
type de finance on s'aperçoit que les
priorités sont bien inférieurs aux
volumes
c'est à dire que une finance qui cherche
à avoir des critères responsable c'est
ce qu'on appelle lit et sert et le sg
donc investissements socialement
responsables et les critères
environnementaux sociaux et de
gouvernance est bas cette finance
représente à peu près 23 mille milliards
c'est-à-dire juste 30 % de ce qui est
gérée par les grandes compagnies
internationales
cela veut dire que plus de 70% sont
investis uniquement pour une
maximisation financière est encore
lorsqu'on parle du srg
il faut savoir que on peut très bien
avoir une bonne note juste en respectant
la loi
en s'occupant bien de ses salariés et en
le détruisant pas trop la planète une
bonne note peut être attribuée
l'entreprise entreprises sans que cette
entreprise est envie de changer le monde
je n'ai pas fait ces constats et
découvert tout cela tout seul c'est bien
en rencontrant des personnes qui savent
d'abord alerté puis après fédérer que
j'ai envie lui envie de passer à
l'action
slow food d'abord et puis ensuite se
mener qui permet de financer le système
local de nourriture également terre de
liens qui
mobilise une épargne militante pour
acheter des terres agricoles et
faciliter l'installation des
agriculteurs en bio et les allégés de la
dette à long terme de l'achat d'une
terre agricole également les plateforme
de crowdfunding certaines ont des
thématiques qui viennent soutenir
l'économie et sociale et solidaire
malheureusement les montants sont
beaucoup trop faibles
ensuite il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle c'est que dans secteur de
l'investissement depuis dix ans aussi
existent linpack investing oui la
finance d'impact permet de rechercher
une performance financière
tout en cherchant à créer un impact
positif et mesurables cette finance
d'impact la bonne nouvelle est qu'elle a
doublé entre 2016 et 2017 quintuplé ces
cinq dernières années et elle représente
228 milliards si vous vous souvenez des
chiffres précédents que j'ai annoncée on
parle donc juste 2 0 linda keen v sting
c'est une finance d'engagement quand je
me suis engagé à financer la logistique
en circuit court
l'économie locale des restaurants des
semences
aucune banque me l'avait proposé
j'étais un petit peu comme le monsieur
jourdain du bourgeois gentilhomme de
molière affaires de limpact investing
sans le savoir comme lui faisait de la
prose sans le savoir est ce que les
solutions j'ai cherché à mettre en place
ce qui m'a passionné
le système local de nourriture est ce
qu'on peut demander à tous les
investisseurs d'avoir la même passion
pour changer leurs façons d'investir
je ne le crois pas je pense qu'il faut
non pas convaincre mais donner envie et
montrer tout simplement que ne pas
prendre en compte ces critères sociaux
et environnementaux est un risque
financier
investir dans des entreprises qui n'ont
pas la conduite voulu d'un point de vue
environnemental et social c'est prendre
un risque parce que les consommateurs se
détournent de ces entreprises
où les externalités négatives vont être
taxés et sanctionnés on le voit
aujourd'hui avec le carbone et le rejet
des consommateurs avec le plastique il
faut donc aussi faire comprendre aux
investisseurs qu une nouvelle économie
se met en place
l'économie du vivant qu'il faut
s'inspirer du vivant là dessus je vais
vous donner deux exemples l'étude d'un
économiste dominique dron qui justement
explique que les marchés financiers sont
fragiles parce qu'il ne repose pas sur
les principes de l'éco système un
écosystème doit avoir une diversité des
acteurs qui ne recherchent pas tous la
même ressource des zones tampon entre
les espèces et boucler le cycle parce
que comme ça il est auto régulée sur les
marchés financiers vous trouvez
uniquement des acteurs semblables de
plus en plus gros qui recherchent la
même ressource
c'est à dire un profit facile à court
terme qui sont connectés en temps réel
une crise à un endroit déclenché une
crise systémique et surtout tout comme
logique l'accumulation et donc tous les
7 ans tous les dix ans tous les 15 ans
vous avez des investissements qui
s'effondre
l'autre exemple c'est l'université de
louvain et l'économie régénératrice qui
prône une économie de la collaboration
au lieu de la compétition de la
régénération au lieu de l'extraction une
économie circulaire pour lesquels les
déchets des uns sont les ressources des
autres et non pas une économie linéaire
qui va extraire transformer et gaspiller
ce n'est pas de la décroissance c'est du
bon sens c'est justement se dire que on
peut introduire dans notre économie
cinq éléments que sont le local le
circulaire le fonctionnel vendre le
service au lieu de vendre un produit
le biomimétisme s'inspirer de la nature
et le collaboratif
lorsque vous pensez inpact investing
avec ces cinq éléments dans ce cas là on
peut parler de la gestion de l'impact
on va aller vers une entreprise pour
l'accompagner vers l'économie
régénératrice et c'est mieux que la
mesure de l'impact plutôt que de se
contenter de diminuer son empreinte
carbone ou de réduire ses déchets ne pas
en créer c'est mieux je vais vous donner
un exemple si une entreprise vient nous
voir pour un financement qui
favoriserait le recyclage de son produit
est ce que vous ne préférez pas une
entreprise qui vient proposer le même
bien qui va finir sa vie chez le
consommateur et donc il n'aura jamais
besoin d'être recyclés n'oubliez pas que
recyclage
c'est à nouveau du transport et
l'énergie donc l'économie régénératrice
et ces cinq éléments c'est également
aller vers une entreprise motiver les
investisseurs pour non plus penser juste
business model mais écosystèmes parce
que quand vous pensez écosystèmes c'est
à portée de l'autonomie et de la
résilience à une entreprise et donc dans
un monde avec un changement climatique
avec des troubles majeurs et des
ruptures de chaîne d'approvisionnement
c'est justement pouvoirs importants
apportés autonomie résilience est donc
une performance financière
également très important c'est que cet
investissement doit se faire en conclut
mythe ans avec un travail international
qui est fait par les gouvernements et
par les conférences internationales
vous avez tous entendu parler de ces
femmes scop et je crois que pour que la
transition écologique soit une réussite
et n'ont pas vécu comme une contrainte
il faut justement apporter du capital de
croissance à ces entreprises et chercher
une convergence entre les lois les
directives et ces nouveaux entrepreneurs
qui réinventent leur secteur
je pense que lorsqu'on investit
maintenant il faut penser au futur aux
générations futures et financier
aujourd'hui les solutions de demain
il faut également penser le changement
plutôt que changer le pansement ça c'est
une phrase que je reprends de francis
blanche et je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle
illustre beaucoup de choses l'actualité
est très importante autour de la
mobilité et des voitures est-ce que vous
pensez que remplacer toutes les voitures
à essence ou diesel par des voitures
électriques de plus de 1500 kg utilisé
par un conducteur individuel une
quinzaine ou une vingtaine de minutes le
matin et le soir est une solution
un individu tout seul dans sa voiture
c'est 5 % de l'énergie qui est utilisé
pour déplacer le véhicule même quatre
personnes dans une voiture on revient à
un ratio de 80 20 la solution n'est-elle
pas plutôt dans le développement de
solutions logistiques qui évite la
mobilité qui permettent par exemple
télétravail ou alors mettre en place une
flotte de voitures légères collective et
mise en commun
ce que je souhaite partager avec vous ce
soir c'est justement cet itinéraire ces
personnes passionnées et passionnantes
que j'ai rencontré en main en
m'engageant vers un autre type
d'investissement je crois que le hasard
des rencontres n'existe pas pour les
personnes qui marchent sur le même
chemin
et ici je pense que spectateur orateur
organisateurs nous sommes tous sur le
même chemin le chemin bon propre et
juste
nous souhaitons trouver un petit peu
l'avant-goût de l'aprem et surtout je
crois le bon goût de la presse et en
conclusion j'aimerais reprendre ce que a
expliqué il ya quelques années un
président américain
et je vois sur bien sûr ce n'est pas
l'actuel président et vous inviter à
vous poser une question puisque tous
directement ou indirectement nous sommes
des investisseurs où nous pouvons nous
pouvons devenir des investisseurs
donc ne vous demandez pas ce que votre
avis
ce moment peut faire pour vous mais
demandez vous ce que vous pouvez rendre
possible avec votre investissement